this alternative use program was
recorded in april of 1987
when the countergate scandal was still
unfolding
we feel very confident that we are going
to be able to document in evidentiary
form
that this team of people have been for a
number of years now dealing in arms and
drugs and using the profits to carry on
a foreign policy which the american
people have no control over here was a
deliberate bombing of a press conference
a conscious strategy that if we kill
united states journalists
at a press conference and get it blamed
on the sandinis to government
we will have achieved a turning of the
american political sentiment against the
nicaraguans bowling amendment said no
direct or indirect military aid to the
congress
they they met in the white house reagan
bush mies and casey
and they decided we have to get around
this congressional ban
and they turn to this same group of
people oliver north was was basically
the manager of the program he's not the
boss he's not the cowboy off the range
like the tower commission report tried
to paint it poindexter and north are
good soldiers following orders the
signals came from the top
we are convinced that out of the
violations of the bowling amendment
and other activities there are clearly
impeachable offenses
for reagan bush and meese casey is out
already i think that's going to be uh an
increasing problem for mr bush if there
is major drug traffic coming into this
country and obviously there is
and if some of it is being done under
the auspices of these you know contra
networks that he helped to set up
and he's in charge of the drug strike
force i think mr bush is in a lot of
trouble somebody asked me in a talk that
i gave do i think this lawsuit will
actually lead back to the impeachment of
reagan and my answer was why aim so low
and
i wasn't being facetious i really mean
that i think there are some of us now
who are committed to not settling for
this or that official going down
we want and i think the american public
wants to know what has been going on so
that we can once again you know just
maybe become a government of the people
two people tell us the incredible story
about america's secret team a group of
terrorists dope smugglers and illegal
arms dealers
operating with the approval of the
highest authorities in the united states
and doing it for decades
join us for this incredible story
tonight on alternative view
[Music]
hey
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
although this program was recorded a few
years ago it contains information and
insights about the conjugate situation
which still have not been presented by
the commercial networks
tonight on alternative views we are
pleased to present lanny sinking and
father bill davis of the christec
institute in washington dc who will
discuss with us the astonishing events
behind the iran contra gate scandals
we'll learn that the key players in both
of these scandals were part of a secret
team which for decades were active in
right-wing politics political
assassinations drug trade and other
criminal activities and we'll try to
give you the full story behind contra
gate tonight so lanny and bill were
pleased to have you with us lanny you're
the chief
or one of the legal attorneys for the
chris deck institute and father bill
davis is one of the chief investigators
could you tell us a bit about the chris
tech institute and how you got involved
in this investigation surely the kristic
institute is a non-profit interfaith
public interest law firm and public
policy center
all of which is to say that we take
legal cases that have a major public
policy dimension
we litigate them to win we also do the
public education and organizing that's
important to change the policies that
created the conditions that led to the
lawsuit
and now we're working on what we call
the lapenca case or the conjugate case
and how does this story begin
the story really begins
for us with a press conference called by
den pastora
in the jungles of nicaragua just across
the border from costa rica
a location called lepenka nicaragua
pastora had called this press conference
to denounce the central intelligence
agency for pressuring him to put himself
under the leadership of adolfo calero
and the fdn the contra force based in
honduras pastora had an independent
contra force in costa rica he considered
the fdn to be dominated by the somoza
national guardsmen and he wanted nothing
to do with them the cia wanted a unified
contra command so that they could run
the contra war more efficiently
the cia at the end of april in 1984 had
said to pastora you have 30 days to put
yourself under the fdn command and join
a unified command or else
they did not specify what the or else
was
in may 30th 1984 pastora called his
press conference to denounce the cia
and at that press conference was a man
who called himself pair anker hanson
pretending to be a danish journalist
carrying an aluminum camera case
in the bottom of that aluminum camera
case was a sophisticated c4 explosive
device
also with shrapnel in it to make it
appear more crude later when it blew up
and
hansen who we now know is named amok
galil and i'll talk about him a little
later but he planted that bomb at the
pastora press conference went outside
and detonated it eight people were
killed 28 people were injured pastora
escaped injury
and the u.s press tried to blame it on
the combination of the
of gaddafi the libyans and nicaragua did
they not actually they said the
terrorist who planted the bomb was a
basque terrorist a basque fantastic uta
and train who had been working for the
nicaraguan government
one of the journalists present during
the bombing tony avragon who was
covering it for abc television was
seriously injured he is one of our
plaintiffs his wife is martha honey
another united states journalist working
in costa rica costa rica they are the
two plaintiffs in our case and they
began an investigation as to who had
done the bombing they heard this story
about the basque terrorists working for
the nicaraguan government they tracked
it down found out that the bass
terrorists was in fact
under house arrest in france at the time
and couldn't possibly have participated
but then they began to hear another
story
um a young man named david came to a
costa rican actually it's an interesting
little story there david came into a bar
with a group of people
most of the group left he was alone he
walked up to a table to a costa rican
who was sitting there having a beer and
said i've got to talk to somebody and he
proceeds to tell this costa rican
carpenter carlos chinchilla a story
about an international brigade
based on a ranch in costa rica that has
been engaging in terrorist activities
that was responsible for the bombing of
the pastora press conference that is
composed of representatives of the fdn
and calero
american mercenaries american
paramilitary groups and all operating
off of the ranch of a man named john
hull
a cia operative in costa rica and that
they were responsible for the bombing at
the le panca press conference that they
also have a plan to blow up the united
states embassy in costa rica and
assassinate the united states ambassador
lewis tams blame that on the sandinista
government and provoke an outrage in the
united states and a direct u.s military
intervention against nicaragua
carlos happens to know some people who
know tony avagon and martha honey the
journalists
he goes to those people they get in
touch with the journalists and pretty
soon david's story is being transmitted
to tony avagon and martha honey and they
start to see this broader network of
terrorist activity seeming to have
official united states government
sanction they hold a press conference to
announce the plan to bomb the embassy
and kill ambassador tams in order to
stop the plot and do succeed in doing
that
as a result they are subject to death
threats
david their source is later kidnapped
and tortured and terrored and murdered
and
they they continue nonetheless their
investigation very courageous pair of
journalists i mean they went after the
story they didn't stop despite the
threats despite the killing of their
news source they continued their story
and were they also the group that
discovered that a drug ring was operated
on john hall's ranch in costa rica what
they are one of them that
cocaine was coming in major quantities
out of colombia on to john hull's ranch
and that it was being shipped then from
john hall's ranch into the united states
pilots bringing weapons illegally out of
the united states down to john hull's
ranch for this southern front of a
contra effort were bringing the cocaine
back into the united states on their
airplanes there was another whole
shipping thing using shrimp boats
going into miami at one point they were
bringing one ton of cocaine a week into
miami as part of the operation
our investigation to date indicates more
and more
that the
contra operation they were trying to set
up in costa rica
to displace aden pastora and put their
own in place was in fact little more
than a cover for this major drug
connection that they were making costa
rica being a perfect stopping off point
from colombia halfway going to the
united states now was this
done just for profit or was it part of
the way to
help pay for the bills of the contras
and to get more money for the contras
which the cia couldn't get out of the
congress
a lot of both i mean there there was
some of the proceeds from the sales of
the drugs were used to buy additional
arms
explosives ammunition uniforms for the
contras some of it went into the pockets
of the people who were involved
and a lot of it of course went to the
people selling the drugs pablo escobar
jorge ochoa two of the biggest colombian
drug lords were the connection the
cocaine connection for the contras
in fact the plot to kill ambassador tams
in the bomb the costa rican embassy had
as one side benefit for the plotters
that pablo escobar in colombia had put a
million dollar price tag on ambassador
tam's head
based on ambassador tam's activities in
in colombia trying to get them
extradited when he was there when he
moved to costa rica they put the million
dollar price tag on his head they
planned to collect the million dollars
from escobar after they killed tams and
blame tan's death on the sandonista
government so there are lots of
different motivations all at the same
time
um and in some cases it's a mixture of
patriotism and profiteering in some
cases it's straight profiteering i mean
some of the people directly involved in
the drug business could care less who
the client is
they're just moving drugs making money
and getting it done and the arms dealers
as well the arm shipments coming out of
florida we're coming from major arms
dealers in the united states who don't
care really that much who the client is
they want to sell the arms and make the
money there was the overlay of this
contra war that gave them the vehicle
for establishing this pipeline and
moving their goods and supplies and
making a lot of money off can you tell
us how your lawsuit and documentation of
these events has attempted to publicize
the event it's important first of all to
just say briefly the legal theory behind
it how we came to
the secret team through this lawsuit
because on the surface of it it's simply
a personal injury in costa rica but
rather than
in name as defendants the ones who were
immediately involved at lepenka we went
one step further back and we said that
that injury really resulted from an
illegal conspiracy within the united
states a conspiracy to open a southern
front against nicaragua it's in
violation of the neutrality act in
violation of the arms export various
banking laws etc and obviously the drug
laws and so in the lawsuit
we named some 29 individuals a lot of
whom at that time were relatively
unknown like richard c cord his business
partner albert hakeem and so on and so
forth now why did we do that the reason
we did was that first of all we wanted
to get back at the roots of this problem
and we wanted to use the lawsuit as a
mother load of information to the
american public about what's really
going on
and one of the laws invoked is the
so-called ricoh law it's a racketeering
law rico stands for racketeer influenced
and corrupt organizations active it was
a law to get at organized crime
we said that all of these men are
involved
in one or the other aspect of a federal
racketeering enterprise which includes
not just illegal arms sales as has now
been verified through the iran
affair that has been made public but has
for years included the the use of drugs
illegal drug traffic
as a way of profiteering and funding
their operations so
basically what the lawsuit is saying is
that there is in effect a secret team or
almost a shadow government that's
operating a group of international
plumbers that has at least the silent
approval of the government
many of the folks in that secret team
are in fact people who came out of
government jobs either the military or
the intelligence agencies and
we feel very confident that we are going
to be able to document in evidentiary
form
that this team of people have been for a
number of years now dealing in arms and
drugs and using the profits to carry on
a foreign policy which the american
people have no control over
can we specify some of this and talk
about names yes and the history right
now we've talked mainly about costa rica
a small operation but this like you said
is right this goes this goes much much
much larger
the
let me just name some of the individuals
first of all who are defendants we named
of course john hull we named the bomber
amak galil we named a number of cuban
americans who were involved down there
but when we came back to start going
upstairs we started basically right
outside the door of lieutenant colonel
oliver north we did not name government
officials in this lawsuit we felt it
would be better if if congress would go
after that and now because of the
revelations that our lawsuits made
congress is going after that but we took
oliver north's
personal representative a man named
robert owen we named him as a defendant
we named
former uh general richard c cord uh his
business partner albert hakeem
thomas posey the man who runs civilian
military assistance program he used to
call it military assistance now that
they've discovered the neutrality act
he's changed it to materiel assistance
general john singlaub former general
john singlaub all people who purport to
be in the private area but as a matter
of fact they set up in the private area
only because it has become more
convenient for various political and
economic reasons to do so
all of these people were involved
in
some rather interesting previous work
with the government let me just give you
a very brief overview of some of them we
feel that theodore shaklee and thomas
kleins two of our defendants their
former cia agents
uh men who for years worked with ed
wilson the man who is now in jail for
selling explosives and
training terrorists in libya
they we really first ran into them back
in the 60s
shaklee was the cia station chief in
florida and kleins was his chief
assistant when a program was set up to
harris castro to try to overcome what
castro had done in cuba and they were
sending speed boats out to burn
crops and blow up bridges and that sort
of thing as a matter of fact a little
known
aspect of that program is that it was
shut down
because the speed boats were were caught
red-handed bringing drugs back
and so rather than prosecute people what
happened was it was all hushed up and
people like shaklee then moved to be cia
assistant station chief in laos and he
took klein's with him he also took with
him a little known
assassination team basically i don't
know what else to call it that would be
more gentle but under the under the
harassment of castro a special team was
set up
that was basically a shooter team some
very interesting characters on that
among them people like rolando martinez
and frank sturgis some of the watergate
burglars yeah but also on that team was
a man named felix rodriguez whom
hossenfuss called max gomez and whom the
vice president has met with at least
three times that we know of and calls
him a great patriot
felix rodriguez and posada carrillos
internationally known terrorists were
part of that original team back in the
60s they also were used then in laos
where a much larger drug operation got
underway
there was
official sanction for working with a man
named vang pao in that area one of the
opium lords his rivals were mysteriously
assassinated so that he got a virtual
monopoly on the opium trade
some of the profits of this were banked
in a c i a front which is known as the
negan hand bank down in australia
the they set up assassination teams over
there to train the hmong tribesmen so
that they could continue to assassinate
any potential communists the pate lao
people like that
so what we what we see developing rather
rapidly in southeast asia
is
the funding of what they call black
operations programs that they couldn't
get past through the ordinary channels
the funding of them by the use of drugs
and illegal arms sales now
that's a that's a very hasty overview i
realize but i want to go on and
make the other connections of where it
moved from there briefly shaklee and
klein's came back to be uh to run the
western hemispheric program in 72 and 73
at the very time incidentally when we
were trying to assassinate allende in
chile after 1973 they go back to
southeast asia by now shaklee has been
promoted to
being the chief of covert operations for
the far east
they ran the infamous phoenix program
out of vietnam which killed literally
thousands of civilians
some estimated as high as sixty thousand
at any rate they were basically
assassinating the infrastructure
teachers clerks mayors anybody who might
be able to run the country once the
communists took over same type of thing
the countries are doing attempting to do
in
nicaragua exactly right and there were
military and intelligence people
involved in it there were also some of
these so-called private teams that they
were bringing in but they're financing
it
not through official channels when when
vietnam finally shut down in 1975
rather than
close this operation by then they they
literally were hooked on a very heady
operation which involves millions of
dollars and and really involves the
creation of foreign policy where you
don't have to wait for those wimps in
congress you simply fight fire with fire
all of that rationale
rather than close it down in 1975 they
moved it to
iran
and that's why when we have the present
iran
arms scandal you know those folks didn't
just parachute in with their cake and
their bible out of the blue they went
back to an old boy network which has
been operating there for years they they
and part of it again involved an
assassination program killing the
enemies of the shah any quote potential
communists which as a matter of fact
probably did away with most of the
democratic moderates and thereby making
it almost inevitable that only an
ayatollah a religious fundamentalist
could
could get in to overcome the shock but
at any rate by 1978 many of these folks
shaklee and klein's and others who are
named in our lawsuit secord hakeem and
so on
many of these folks went into the
private sector
secord by the way had moved into the
pentagon and become one of the chief
procurement officers so that he's
getting these very large arms sales
going to the companies that these folks
had set up the private companies that
these folks had set up while they were
in the agency they then leave the agency
and become the heads of companies that
are benefiting from these arms deals and
what they're doing
basically they had a number of
of
skimming operations going on but one of
the chief ones was buying arms
at their original cost and reselling
them at replacement values sound
familiar and the difference of course
was not paid back to the pentagon the
difference went to swiss bank accounts
and it then is used to to the
fund these these various operations but
in 1979
they began to move back into central
america because in 79 you'll remember we
had the famous harkin amendment carter
was in power and he was emphasizing
human rights
one of the people officially cut off
from u.s arms was somosa in nicaragua
because of his violation of human rights
it was so gross that they they couldn't
avoid it
not to worry samosa never missed a gun
or a grenade because these folks from
the private sector
who in fact had all these government
connections simply moved in and began to
supply even then and of course once
samosa fell they began to deal with his
generals i.e the contrast they set up
the contras in effect
well if they didn't set them up they at
least began to supply them and to arm
them and to you know carry on basically
their shadow government their their
foreign policy no matter what congress
said and and when they could
they worked it back through government
when reagan came into power
1981 it was okay for the cia to do this
so then they began to cooperate again
with government sources but by 83 wasn't
it they had they were caught mining the
harbors and the assassination manual
remember the assassination manual which
said go ahead and murder clerks mayors
anybody in the infrastructure it was the
same crowd of people in fact one of the
same agents who drafted that
was was later promoted upstairs to be
the head of the cia in costa rica so
this team has been going in and out of
the federal government that's right some
of their members were
active high officials in the cia and the
military then during the carter
administration quite a few of them left
government service did they not to form
more of a private network and it was
this network that oliver north connected
with to run both arms to the countries
and then to operate this drug ring that
financed the operation and these same
folks brought the weap the weapons to
iran it's precisely true they turned to
the same secret team when congress when
it was clear in 1983 that congress was
going to cut off money to the contras
that cut off the aid
no the bowling amendment said no direct
or indirect military aid to the contras
they they met in the white house reagan
bush mies and casey
and they decided we have to get around
this congressional ban
and they turn to this same group of
people oliver north was was basically
the manager of the program he's not the
boss he's not the cowboy off the range
like the tower commission report tried
to paint it poindexter in north are good
soldiers following orders the signals
came from the top
we are convinced that out of the
violations of the bowling amendment
and other activities there are clearly
impeachable offenses for reagan bush and
miese casey is out already
but the signal was given
and they turned to the secret team the
secret team went into action
then you have the iranian situation with
the hostages
it's clear that the single most
important hostage was mr buckley
he was a the cia station chief in
lebanon who was kidnapped off the
streets of lebanon taken to iran
tortured and made a massive confession
to much of the kinds of activities that
we are now discussing
they were desperate to get buckley out
and part of the arms deal was an effort
to say to the iranians we'll give you
weapons give us back buckley
there is one story that has come our way
it's not confirmed in our view yet
that in fact buckley gave a videotaped
confession to the iranians about all of
this secret activity about which he was
very familiar he knew all of this stuff
and that the iranians use the videotape
material to in fact blackmail the reagan
administration into sending the arms
that the arms are really hush money to
the iranians so these videotapes don't
go into circulation
but it is the same group of people and
it's an operation they're used to they
have planes available to them they have
arms merchants available to them they
were it was a simple matter to help the
israelis or get this danish shipping
groups or go to portugal wherever they
had to go they could service this need
the government had to do a secret
operation that the american people would
have clearly rejected as they did when
they heard about it selling arms to the
ayatollah was perhaps the single most
politically explosive thing that came
out so far i think when we get to the
cocaine smuggling that will overshadow
it it's important to realize that these
folks knew the drill because they had
been doing it for years i think it's
very important to see
the contra effort and the present
scandal in that larger context
we live in washington
there's a lot of sentiment in washington
that oh this was just an aberration and
what we have to do is get it all behind
us much as we did you know during
watergate we made a great effort to get
it all behind us rather than to look at
what's going on here what is the pattern
is this not perhaps a real
constitutional crisis these folks i
would maintain are basically subversives
they're using the same logic that they
used in vietnam where they said you know
we had to destroy the village in order
to save it they're saying we're willing
to subvert democracy in order to save it
but it's it's totally
violating the system of checks and
balances that have been set up in this
country
and
they really i think they're subversives
in the strict sense of that word now
we've been talking kind of about the
secret team and
a group of
cia and xcia people and some pentagon
people thrown in here and there
this makes it sound as if it's just kind
of a renegade group
operating kind of independently
is it not more possible that they're
they're i can't imagine these activities
going unknown and uncoordinated by the
uh
see and that's why some of the history
that i went into is important because
most of these folks were doing similar
things while they were officials of
government shaklee and kleins were cia
officials for years
shackley as a matter of fact that before
he resigned he was the head of covert
operations for the entire world
appointed by george bush by the way who
is presently vice president
so you know these folks have we're doing
it as officials of the government and
even now the so-called private network
we know that it couldn't possibly
operate without government approval you
know fortunately we had the haasenfuss
event in the plane that went down in
nicaragua in october and before mr
hassanfoss hit the ground talking uh and
revealed the fact that he had been
operating out of ilopongo air force base
i mean a military base in
el salvador you don't get on that base
without official
salvadoran government approval and u.s
approval we now know from a number of
sources that the government people knew
and aided they knew about the so-called
private network they aided and abetted
it all up and down the line and there's
another answer too to your question
about the government had to know
at some points in this scenario there's
there are people in the government who
are opposed to what's happening
but the people that are engaged in all
these racketeering and criminal
activities
are essentially gray mailing
the intelligence community that if you
try and stop me or
arrest me or prosecute me i'll tell
about all that other stuff i did while i
was in the government that we did while
we were in it because the whole agency
was doing
vietnam and after that's right
so they have that kind of protection of
being able to gray mail the people who
might otherwise stop them yet it looks
like the reagan administration is
engaging in a systematic process of
damage control they're trying to cover
over
the aspects of the iran contra gate
scandal that you're trying to bring to
light well as i mentioned the tower
commission report was
essentially an effort to portray this as
a momentary aberration some guys in the
national security council just let it go
to their heads and went out and did all
these outrageous things and and we
really just need to tighten up the
procedures on the national security
council so that they are not allowed to
participate directly in covert
operations and that will cure the
problem and oliver north and john
poindexter's an unfortunate incident in
our national history and we can put that
behind us tower commission said we don't
know a whole lot about that contra stuff
but others are going to look into that
well that was damage control that was
putting a spin on the story that that
whole business of putting a spin on the
story that's come out i mean they just
like to take a reality and twist it
but that was damage control
then they've appointed a special
prosecutor
which is another part of the executive
branch response to some extent to the to
the crisis but from what we understand
the special prosecutor is now looking at
probably indicting oliver north
for having engaged in
private activity on government time
thereby defrauding the government of his
salary that this was a private operation
this whole thing was private when oliver
north was off working on it he was doing
private stuff on government time and
they're worried about him using nsc
stationery and things like that
so
if if ever there was a superficial
approach to the problem indicting oliver
north for embezzling
the government defrauding them of his
time is a superficial approach
we are working with the staff of the
special prosecutor we are providing them
with the information from our
investigation and urging them to take a
much broader view of the people the
events and the historical context
because that's the only way we're going
to solve the ultimate policy problem
here
that's the executive branch in the
legislative branch you have the senate
select committee the house select
committee
a little bit of activity in the house
judiciary subcommittee on crime they are
looking into the drugs
and the senate foreign relations
committee is also looking into certain
matters but both of those have limited
staffs neither of the other committees
other than the select committees have
the power to grant immunity to witnesses
so their investigations will go a
certain distance but not too far all of
this is so interconnected that if they
pursue any aspect of the investigation
they get to the story that you're trying
to get out that's exactly right and
we're grateful for these different
committees all looking into it we think
however that it's absolutely crucial
that folks at the grassroots let their
committee members know their congress
people their senators know
that they want the whole thing looked at
because obviously political people will
do political things democrats love to
show that some of this was abused during
a republican administration they aren't
going to be too anxious to look at the
broader picture some of which happened
under democratic administrations so we
feel we're grateful that the
congressional
committees are going forward we feel
that it's very important that there be a
civil suit such as ours in the private
sector so that there is a kind of a
check on congress and we also feel that
it's extremely important that the
citizens
demand that people get to the bottom of
this rather than get get behind it i
mean congress will generally do
more or less what the citizens demand
that it does and not much more
well what is happening how does this
connect up with uh howard baker and and
his emergence as the
president behind the scene the president
behind the scenes i i can tell you what
we hear in washington and and some of
this is probably speculation it just
seems to make some sense
uh once the scandal really began to
break
the republican party went to ronald
reagan and said you work for us we're
not going to go down the tubes over this
scandal so we are going to start making
some decisions here ronald reagan wanted
to put mr gates as head of the c.i.a a
man who had been involved in this whole
situation
deputy director director oh that's right
casey they wanted to move him up when
casey went to the hospital
they blocked that the republican party
blocked that said it will not be gates
we will not risk
the appearance of a cover-up you must
have someone of of impeccable
credentials and high credibility the
best they could find was william webster
from the fbi who's now
being going through his confirmation
process and is probably under the
circumstances the best person they could
have come up with
then he wanted to put paul laxalt in as
his chief of staff
to replace don regan
and they said no
enough of the right-wing conservatives
sitting and telling you what to do
laxalt also according to mother jones
and several other investigations had
connections with organized crime from
some of his uh activities in nevada i
think so he's at least tarnished i've
read those stories i think probably a
far more concern to the republican party
was
the policy dimension we have to get the
white house out from under the control
of these far-right adventurists who have
gotten it into this mess so we want
someone as your chief of staff who's a
moderate republican
impeccable credentials untainted by the
scandal and they turn to howard baker
and there he is
now one of the stories floating about in
washington is that the ultimate damage
control plan
is that if vice president bush
is forced to resign because of
revelations about his involvement in
this whole secret effort
then the plan would be to appoint howard
breaker as the vice president
reagan is now being geared towards
signing some arms control agreement with
the soviet union enough of that
right-wing
evil empire stuff let's get an arms
agreement clean up your image
historically and let you go home and
wait for the nobel peace prize
so he does he does the agreement with
the soviets
and he retires gracefully from the
presidency
for whatever reason they think up and
baker becomes the president
then they move into 1988
with a moderate untainted incumbent
candidate for the republican party and
they're in great shape now this as i say
it speculates the washington rumor mill
and you hear it through that but it
certainly makes a lot of sense it also
follows the pattern that richard nixon
used
agnew had to go up came forward nixon
had to go up came forward ford goes in
no scandal other than the pardon of
nixon but there he is right bill on this
1988 election issue what is the evidence
against bush that makes it appear that
he will be tainted by this
well of course bush is not one of the
defendants in our lawsuit but his name
is coming up in many different ways
i think the most obvious one is his
immediate connection with this so-called
private network
something that was absolutely forbidden
by the bolan amendment that they were
not to help either directly or
indirectly
we now know because of the haasenfuss
plane and various other things that a
lot of it goes right back to george
bush's office donald gregg his assistant
was the man who is a matter of fact
recruited felix rodriguez and some of
these other operatives in the private
network
i think a far
bigger problem brewing for mr bush is
going to be the whole drug problem he
was as i mentioned in charge of the cia
at a time when
apparently a lot of drug activity was
taking place under official auspices out
of southeast asia he is now in charge of
the national strike force on drugs
we've been told by various sources that
what is happening in fact
is that the strike force is cleaning up
the drug traffic that is to say they're
going out and busting the wildcatters
and the entrepreneurs and the people who
aren't online so they're cleaning it up
in that sense of creating a monopoly and
the main lines aren't being touched i
think that's going to be
uh an increasing problem for mr bush if
there is major drug traffic coming into
this country and obviously there is and
if some of it is being done under the
auspices of these you know contra
networks that he helped to set up
and he's in charge of the drug strike
force i think mr bush is in a lot of
trouble and didn't bush when he was head
of the cia as you indicated earlier
appoint shockley to a high cia post who
is involved in the drug trade in vietnam
yes so there's another drug connection
that bush is
involved with
and i think you will see even more come
out as time goes on the task force on
terrorism
is going to be revealed to have a lot of
people involved with it that they
eventually got
caught up in the whole oliver north
secret network
situation so i mean
those who really know what's happened
could certainly sit down and say well
george if it all comes out you're going
to have to go so we better be prepared
to deal with that
you know you
there are other people involved in this
framework which you're talking about or
their interlocks or interconnects
the covert action information bulletin
for this particular time period talks
about the
interconnects of
with a religious right talks about
general singh lab and oliver north
uh being on the board of governors of
the council for national policy which is
a right-wing
organization and pat robertson was the
president yeah i i think that's a very
important element to feed in
i mentioned before in 1978 when people
like shackley and kleins went into the
private sector they went into the
private corporate sector
shortly after that we had general
singlaub getting fired from north korea
remember because of his effectery to
carter
he went into a very interesting part of
the private sector that is the religious
private sector he became the head of a
thing known as the world anti-communist
league it received major funding from
the unification church the so-called
mooney church
it is rapidly anti-communist
it is neo-nazi in its mentality it has
direct ties with the death squads in
central america there's an interesting
book called inside the league by the way
which details a lot of this but i think
the i think the thing that you touch on
there the right wing religious
motivation
is very important to keep in mind i
think when an oliver north tells the
press you know look up the 8th beatitude
which is the one about
you know blessed are those who are
persecuted for justice sake those folks
aren't just manipulating religion i
think he really believes that i think
they see themselves as messianic figures
who are who are stemming the tide of
communism and and you know fighting
against the evil empire notice how
reagan and many of his people beg have
begun to use theological terms i think
they really believe that and that
that in a way that's even more scary to
be a true believer they they are able
therefore to justify almost anything
they do
because they are the saviors of western
civilization and and they're fighting
against the the evil empire i.e
communism and there is this whole
framework
of interconnects and organizations and
structures with a religious right
and the cia
and the mafia all throughout absolutely
central and and
south america lanny said earlier uh the
combination of uh profiteering and uh
patriotism is a very heady combination
that's true when you add in a religious
rationale
so whereby you become almost a crusader
a messianic figure
it's even more of a heady combination
now april the 11th and the question that
rises in my mind how much of this story
is going to get out do you see the media
going into this covering this and what
have you been trying to do to try to get
the story out about the secret team and
the truth behind the iran conjugate
scandal it's very difficult to get it
out but i will tell you we're not going
to stop until it is out we don't want to
have you know a resignation here or even
an impeachment there somebody asked me
in a talk that i gave do i think this
lawsuit will actually lead back to the
impeachment of reagan and my answer was
why aim so low
and i wasn't being facetious i really
mean that i think there are some of us
now who are committed to not settling
for this or that official going down we
want and i think the american public
wants to know what has been going on so
that we can once again you know just
maybe become a government of the people
one of the things that i might add you
asked about you know the media getting
this out and so on as a matter of fact
we named many of those names almost a
year ago we filed this lawsuit on may 29
1986 and
hardly anyone noticed now of course
partly due to the events of the time
like caution first and certainly the
iran scam names like c chord and hakeem
and robbo and so on are much more the
lawsuit is being taken much much more
seriously but it illustrates the fact
that
things don't get out until a climate
builds up i i think there is no
salvation for a democracy better than an
informed public as a public get more and
more informed than things like this
lawsuit like the other investigations
that are going on are much more likely
to succeed we were talking about the
media or mentioning it you tried to
bring this information out on nightline
ted koppel's program can you tell us
what happened to you uh that was a
really a humorous event they had a show
called viewpoint that was replacing
nightline it was about the press and the
presidency and are we bashing the
president too much
and this
crazed group of media critics took it
over for an hour and we finally got a
moment in to talk about the substance of
the issue
and i said to ted koppel i said i don't
believe you can possibly bash the
presidency too much when the president
has put in place a policy that results
in massive amounts of cocaine being
smuggled into this country
well koppel just about fell out of his
chair he just couldn't handle it he said
i've never heard anybody link the white
house to cocaine i mean you've just done
it on national television but that
doesn't i just can't believe it i said
well it's true and we filed an affidavit
in federal court in miami in a lawsuit
for the acoustic institute to say how
it's been done and who did it so that
was it was a quick blip
uh but we knew it was coming and we
wanted to start telling people in this
country and
like the media usually do they just blew
it off we gave him a copy of the
affidavit for him to read and he was
asked later about it and he said well
i've never seen anything about the
christian studies and i know what's
going on it's a very hot potato they
don't want to touch it until someone
else does first
we're getting there some of the major
media are covering the story it is
getting out i should also say that we
are working
through
organizations and individuals all over
the country to get this information out
we have formed a communications alliance
of national organizations
religious denominations that have joined
in to say we will take your information
and we will transmit it to the people we
communicate with the communications
alliance now has
organizations that talk to about 120
million people in this country we are
forming an advisory committee for our
case bringing on major religious leaders
we're working to get business leaders
labor leaders other leaders onto that
case to say this case is important and
the american people should watch what's
happening here because here's what we're
going to find out
where we're going to find out what's
really going on in this country
now there was this rather anomalous
report on cbs and a longer treatment on
west 52nd street 557.
if my math is right but anyway they
actually did come out with a story on
that we're talking about the
drugs and all and the cia and there will
be more of that in the near future
however it was not picked up by any of
the other networks it was not picked up
by
the new york times or by the washington
post that's right and that's the kernel
of the establishment you think that uh
first of all
but the story's been there yes why did
cbs just now do it and why did the other
media not pick it up
that's a very complex question
a number of media people have told us
the media doesn't really want to be out
front they love to be sort of close to
the front getting the scoops but not you
know the media is major media anyhow are
basically weather veins they will say
what they know people are ready to hear
i mean for months they knew about the
bombing of cambodia and sat on it didn't
you know didn't bring it out until
enough of a groundswell had built up in
opposition to what we were doing in
southeast asia then they tell the story
the groundswell i think is building
there are literally thousands of people
millions of people in this country who
know that our central america policy is
bananas i feel no fun
uh
and you know it it's building up to the
point where i think the major media will
be touching it soon but why one group
does it ahead of another you'll notice
that it was only a kind of a
semi-independent organization within cbs
that told that story
washington post and new york times enjoy
great reputations for being you know
liberal investigative press frankly we
don't see much of that i think they're
much more into damage control than they
are into investigative groundbreaking
well they are the establishment they get
co-opted
i mean
they are the establishment press because
the establishment is willing to talk to
them on a regular basis and that's
corrosive of an independent press i saw
a piece a newsweek person wrote in
newsweek
saying there we were with oliver norris
at the oliver north as a major source
and we knew a little bit about what he
was doing but we knew if we covered that
we'd lose him as a source for all these
other things we were finding out so
rather than blow his cover we kept him
as a source and that co-opted us into
the government
so that kind of thing happens it happens
in lots of different ways if the
publisher of a major newspaper is
consulted on a regular basis by the
president or the president's staff as to
what they're doing or intelligence
agencies or intelligence agencies they
feel they're part of the government
and that they don't want to cover
stories that are going to cause a major
upheaval in the country and threaten the
stability of the process that they are
such an important part of there's
another another final piece on that for
me if ever there was a time the press
should be responding it's to this case
we're filing we have filed and are
litigating because here was a deliberate
bombing of a press conference a
conscious strategy that if we kill
united states journalists
at a press conference and get it blamed
on the sandinista government
we will have achieved a turning of the
american political sentiment against the
nicaraguans and we will use these
members of the journalistic community as
our pawns
to achieve that political end
and they were building off of something
that had happened
in nicaragua under samosa where samosa's
national guard killed a united states
journalist just murdered him on the
street
and the american people turned against
samosa so they said hey that's the
scenario let's kill american journalists
make them think the sandinistas did it
and turn them against
against the sanonises well if any
community in this country has a stake in
what we're doing it's the journalistic
community and if there ever was a time
here we are in the 200th anniversary of
the united states constitution
we're looking at the press the free
press the first amendment and a direct
attack upon them that threatens their
ability to gather news without becoming
targets
it's a perfect time for them to step
forward and say okay we're going to be
embraced by the constitution and we're
going to embrace the constitution we're
going to tell you the truth about what's
going on in this country in the world so
that you can use the constitutional
system to make it right so you can be an
informed electorate giving your informed
consent to policies that are going on
and not have any policies going on that
don't have your informed consent i might
note that the kristak institute has
published an affidavit of daniel sheehan
who's one of the members of your group
that gives all the information on the
show
that we've covered today that goes into
the whole history basically
it basically tells what it is we know
and how we came to know it and it's
available to the public how can
people get in touch with the chris deck
institute and find out about your work
and the information that you have we're
in washington dc the address there if
folks want to write is 1324
north capitol street in washington d.c
and the zip is two triple zero two
so folks can write to us and and
receive that or write to us and be uh be
listed on uh be regular recipients of
updates on this case you have a phone
number there too yes it's area two zero
two
and to conclude in a minute or so we
have left what's the next step for the
trial
well we're presently in the stage that's
known as discovery it means that the
judge has now ruled it's a valid suit
legally we now have subpoena power not
just over these individuals but over
documents very wide subpoena power
because of the racketeering law he said
that the racketeering claim uh prevails
so all of their motions to to dismiss
the suit have been denied we have now
begun to take depositions and that will
go on for some time uh the trial may not
happen for a year or more but the
important thing is that this discovery
period will all be available to the
public we see a tremendous opportunity
here
whatever the select committees do on the
congress whatever the special prosecutor
does this case is like a plow it's
opening up the ground and showing what's
going on in this secret network in these
covert wars this foreign policy carried
out through racketeering and criminal
activity and we're offering the american
people an opportunity to change that
policy it's something they didn't have
in watergate you know nixon resigned
everybody went that's over
they didn't have it in vietnam the
vietnam war was stopped but no one ever
really got a handle on what went on
there here is the opportunity to see
how the constitutional processes are
being avoided how democracy is being
subverted as
father davis said and to make the
changes the fundamental policy changes
that are necessary to prevent this from
happening again the next six months or
so the next year is going to be very
critical in the history of the united
states because
if we're ever really going to be a
government of the people the people have
to know how power is being exercised
we have a lot of people to thank our
director david galicic camera people
judy burton stephanie beavers
karen rupert our audio man was richard
jones and of course a big thank you to
austin community television ac tv for
the use of their equipment
alternative views is a production of the
alternative information network po box
7279
austin texas
78713
nine